okay so being british i'm normally
asleep when the academy awards happen
most of the time they're pretty boring
and by the numbers and you can just
snooze through most of them and just
check twitter the next day to see who
got what waking up this morning i
couldn't believe what i saw and i'm sure
as many of you know will smith slap
chris rock during the oscars after he
made a joke about his wife jada pinkett
smith feels like i'm in some weird
timeline where one of the nicest guys in
hollywood snapped and almost every
youtuber at this point is scrambling to
put something together like will smith's
publicist it's the slap heard around the
world so what the hell happened well
during the ceremony chris rock cracked a
joke about jada and will got up on stage
hit him and then repeatedly told him to
keep his wife's name out of his mouth
you know who's got the hardest job
tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
[Laughter]
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's javascript that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
[Laughter]
oh
wow wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth i'm
going to okay
so i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
this is getting meme to hell with many
comparing it to the reason will was sent
to bel air in the first place and
they're also saying that this is gonna
be the last oscars ever i definitely
think it'll be the most memorable one
and it's difficult to think if there'll
ever be a time where this isn't talked
about every time the show is on now
comedians over the decades have always
cracked jokes at the oscars and these
are normally taken in the spirit that
they're given where rox kind of walks
the line a bit is that jada has alopecia
and thus a bald joke is kind of making
fun of a disease rather than it being
something ego related now i don't think
chris was aware of that but he's not
really said anything otherwise you can
actually catch you all laughing at the
jug before he comes on stage and this is
definitely why chris was chuckling as he
came up to him now will smith actually
went on to win best actor for his role
in king richard but this entire
situation has completely overshadowed
the whole thing here's his speech oh man
[Applause]
richard williams
was a
fierce defender of his family
in this
time in my life
in this
moment
i am
overwhelmed
by what god is calling on me to do and
be in this world
making this film
i got to protect
anjanu ellis
who was one of the most
the strongest
most delicate people i've ever met
i got to protect
sanaya
and demi
the two actresses that played venus and
serena
[Applause]
i'm being called on
in my life
to love people
and to protect people
and to be a river to my people
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay
but richard williams
and what i loved thank you dee
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
now you got people cheering for him
standing up for his wife some saying he
went too far and everyone is weighing in
what happened there's even reports that
he might have to hand his oscar back
because he's violated academy rules and
though rock isn't pressing charges it's
a very bad look now i kind of went
through a mix of emotions when watching
the clip and after the shock i was
actually stunned to the point i didn't
know where i came down on it after
thinking about it and seeing all the
reactions i think this is a really bad
look and that'll probably loom over
smith's career for a long time well will
smith did tonight with straight [ __ ]
props and congratulations to him for
winning the oscar because damn it he
deserved it
and i love the brother and i'm proud of
him but boy was that a shameful act for
him to commit tonight
to go up on stage and slap chris rock
like that he's lucky he didn't get his
ass kicked particularly after the event
was over if not by chris rock to the
fellas he had there with him i mean damn
denzel and bradley cooper and tyler
perry having to calm you down your
publicist having to run out and calm you
down i mean damn come on bro
come on man
there's no excuse for it ladies and
gentlemen don't even try to justify it
okay
chris rock said it years ago every time
black folks doing something you know who
messes it up i never dreamed of my
wildest dreams i'd be saying that about
will smith a black man will packer did a
phenomenal job producing the oscars and
you do this to stain yourself to stain
the academy awards
damn
and that's pretty much where i come down
on it too i think that stand-up comedy
has its own context and that when you go
after people for jokes they make during
it like you're stepping outside of the
medium and taking it to somewhere that
it shouldn't go again stand-up is a
medium and with that comes the notion
that everything said in it shouldn't be
taken seriously
will even laughed at the joke initially
and then probably as he took a second to
think about it he got very heated to me
it's not the right thing to do and
though his wife was made fun of during
the awards assaulting rock publicly for
the world to see was the wrong way to go
about it i think that the meta should
have been handled privately away from
the cameras because it's really soured
the entire thing and completely
overshadowed the whole event i think
smith is basically a man who's been at
breaking point for a long time and often
the person who makes the cup spill over
gets the full repercussions of it when
rock was just making what he thought was
gonna be a fun joke jader and will have
been bagged on for quite a while over
the whole entanglement thing that was
made public last year and their dirty
laundry has been aired for the whole
world just feels like smith broke and
i'm sure in respect that he feels he
shouldn't have lost his temper like that
as he's apologized for doing it it could
also lead to his oscar being stripped
from him as he's broken that cut of
conduct and yet all that hard work can
be whisped away in a second if you do
something like this now this is going to
be really highly debated and for every
meme tweet and reaction you see there's
an equal and opposite one saying
something different just tons of people
weighing in which i think kind of
supports my thoughts that it should have
been dealt with privately hell i don't
even make videos like this but it's such
a big thing that's rocked the movie
community that i had to talk about it
unintentional pun aside yeah i do this
as a job full-time so excuse me for
covering this as it's just something
that we have to talk about because it's
such a big story coming out the awards
now because of this i think that the
negative discourse has arisen from these
shows it was a negative act and for
every person saying you're supposed to
defend your wife like that you've then
got others bringing up the entanglement
and it's just messy this is a sensitive
subject and i think everyone's initial
first reactions might change as the day
goes on it's really set a bad example
and kindly shows chris rock takes a
punch better than will smith takes a
joke it's really messed up and obviously
everyone is gonna have their opinions on
whether they think it's acceptable or
not i know dislikes have been disabled
but hit that thumbs up button if you
agree it was wrong and hit the thumbs
down if you think smith was right
there's no way to really see this stuff
anymore unfortunately but if dislikes
don't mean anything then likes probably
don't mean anything either but heyo
that's youtube now you can also leave a
comment discussing your point of view
and i'm really interested to see where
people come down on this make sure you
let me know and if you want something a
bit more positive to watch then check
out our breakdown of the flash going
into the speed force which will be on
screen right now that won the oscar
cheer moment last night and it's kind of
more in line with what we typically tend
to do here anyway i hope you enjoy the
rest of your day no doubt this will be
talked about a lot so buckle up without
the way i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace